[Music]
all right we're talking about perhaps
the greatest company in the history
of enterprise and business it's called
amazon
and josh silberstein is the ceo of
thorazio t-h-r-a-s-i-o and
they have bought 60 different amazon
sellers
and combined them into one giant entity
where they can use a common platform for
things like marketing and
uh you know managing their reviews doing
seo
doing fulfillment customer support all
those things it's a brilliant idea for a
business raise a couple hundred millions
of dollars
to do it and you're focused on the
amazon platform
have you gone to walmart or target and
said hey why don't you take our
collection of 60 and put them on your
platform and
why isn't walmart or target or somebody
like that ambitious enough to say
let's just copy the third-party seller
program it's so obvious
i mean walmart has they have yeah i mean
they have
and you know part of the the jet.com
acquisition was designed to accelerate
that effort you know i think you know
there's a bit of a network effect it's
it's harder to attract sellers when you
don't have as many buyers and it's
harder to attract buyers when you don't
have as many sellers and
you know it's back to the fact that
amazon has the huge
network of selection on the seller side
and the huge number of buyers
uh if you're amazon and you know walmart
by most counts is five to ten percent
the size of amazon online
and you know the incentive to go and
build a business on walmart isn't this
big on that's amazon now
we do have sales on it on walmart we
think walmart's a great platform we're
happy to work with them
um but the the velocity
that we've been able to get so far on
walmart it's not the same
what if walmart said to you what what is
the percentage that amazon takes from
third-party sellers i don't even know
it's 13 on average 15 on average so
and what is walmart charge is the same
you know i actually don't know
but it's pretty similar if walmart just
said hey you know we're gonna do this
uh anybody who's on the platform in 2020
2021
anybody anybody who joins by the end of
2020 we're going to give you the first
three years
uh one percent or zero percent just for
joining the platform then people would
might direct some of their traffic there
right they might invest more heavily i
wonder why they don't do that
you know the funny thing is that people
aren't always rational and
people like to do things the way they've
been doing them and it usually takes
something big to
get people to change behavior and so
it's i i think you're right i think that
if amazon excuse me if walmart
um offered bigger incentives could they
attract more sellers sure i mean
at walmart still is bigger than amazon
and aggregate they still have plenty of
advantages but
um you know if you ask
and you know stop somebody on the street
and shake them and say hey i need to buy
a product where do i go online
98 of them are going to tell you amazon
at some point you know maybe when you
hit
100 or 600 or 6 000
products in your collection um where we
are actually it's about six thousand
six thousand products across 60
companies so there's a point at time
where
you could sell direct and or open like
retail outlets
or uh even you know create your own
products based on your learnings have
you considered or done any of those or
that is that the road map here is to get
so big
and have so many products that you could
actually be some over
arching brand and thrasio might mean
something to people like
target does so
one i don't think thrazio will ever mean
anything to people thrazio
was a name that was picked out of a hat
for all intents and purposes because my
partner and i like greek mythology
it sounds like a greek it's one of the
amazonian warriors it's thrazzo
but um but we do have we do have a brand
called
zaba that um you know we think of it as
a bottom of the funnel brand because
it's going to apply to everything from
corkscrews to you know
fishing gear or whatever it happens to
be and the idea is that
um unlike old school brands that
embody particular product attributes
in the world you live in now the brands
aren't big enough to to be able to
capitalize on that scale and send that
message out so what you really need
is trust you need quality you need to
have the ability to have
an interaction with somebody over and
over again
where each and every time you get what
you want you get when you wanted it it's
a great experience and so the way we
think about it is that
you know all of the different products
that we have are from different
categories
but they all have one thing in common
which is you know
our commitment that they're a great
product that we're going to do
everything we can to make sure the
customer is happy
all the things that you know every
boring retail business in the history
times is built on
and to the degree to which we can
succeed that
we can build a brand that i think stands
whether it's inside amazon or outside
amazon
for a good customer experience and for
trust and in a world in which the brands
are going to become less familiar that's
going to mean something
are you starting to do your own um
brand creation i mean i would think that
your team is getting so good at
understanding what people want
you could start to become like what's
the company oxo i get a lot of their
products
um you know when i or anker is the other
one i like so when i
i actually go to the anchor page and
click on new releases
and just kind of window shop on amazon i
know that is
i'm uncovering myself as a gadget addict
but
do you start seeing yourself doing that
we do i mean look have you made any yet
have you done any like in the laboratory
probably we have we have 200 or 30 in
the laboratory
none that have been really publicly
released a lot of times it's taking an
existing product and making it better
it's not something where you're coming
up with something all together different
but
there are times when you'll look at a
marketplace and you'll see
that the things that are being offered
either aren't great for the consumer or
the prices aren't right and if you've
got
you know a sourcing superstar like like
we have on our team who
can come back to me in three seconds so
yeah we can buy that for three dollars
and eight cents a unit
we can look at these opportunities and
we could say let's be selective and
smart
and enter these marketplaces but so much
of
you know you made a point earlier in
this in this dialogue about how the
the sort of top 10 lists are set how the
the reviews and the leadership sort of
and how it's difficult to break in and
that's still true and so
if you're going to release a new product
it not only has to be
great by any metric but it also has to
be fundamentally
different there has to be something
about it which is going to make it more
valuable to the consumer
and so you know we've got an initiative
coming up that
um we're not quite ready to announce but
which you know when it comes out i think
we'll make
make some news um that's all about how
do you take
an everyday product and make it
something which someone is going to
love to own in a way that's different
than just it being the best product
yeah i mean if you look at what
kickstarter and indiegogo represented
in terms of the entrepreneurial
ecosystem it was these inventor types
saying i can make something 10 or 20
percent better or i can make something
10 to 20 percent better in five
different aspects which means i can make
something overall 50 or even 100 better
and there was a really interesting
company called quirky that raised far
too much money
i think it was one of these andreessen
horowitz specials where they put too
much money into a company and then it
blows up
uh because they're overfunded but uh i
don't know if you remember quirky
and they were doing crowdsourced air
conditioners and power strips i had one
of their power strips initially which
was like
this very cool one that you can like
bend like a snake so it could
you know kind of conform uh to uh big
power bricks back in the day before we
all had usb-c's
and easy stuff to use like that what did
you think of the quirky idea
uh first i i thought that the
the fundamental concept was good yeah
the idea that you
could come up with uh the ability to
engineer a product that met more
consumer needs by understanding what
consumers thought and crowdsourcing that
that made a lot of sense you know the
challenge in anything is that
you know having a good product is for
better or worse only part of
what you need for success right you need
to be able to market successfully you
need to be able to figure out how to
make the cost for and so on and so forth
and so
you know even though i think that they
probably were able to develop some cool
products that doesn't necessarily mean
it was good business
yeah it seemed like it was the margins
were too low
again back to over funding of startups
if you give
a founder 10 20 whatever millions of
dollars and
they're gonna go put it to use and
you're pushing them to grow too fast
which is what andreessen horowitz was
kind of their specialty for a while was
pushing people to go too fast from what
founders told me
you know you can kind of basically it's
like hitting the gas on a ferrari but
you haven't put the steering wheel on
yet
maybe not advisable